おむすびころりん
ある日おじいさんが
いつものように山で木の枝を切っていた。
お昼ご飯にしようと、おじいさんは切り株に腰かけ
おばあさんの握ったおむすびの包みを開いた。
するとぉ、おむすびが一つ滑り落ちて
山の斜面を転がり落ちていく。
おじいさんが追いかけると
おむすびが
木のねもっ･･根元に
すぃだぁ穴に落ちてしまった。
おじいさんが穴を、、見ると
なにやら声が聞こえてくる。
カァカァ(からす)うるせぇなぁ
省略中(´ω｀*)
家に持ち帰った。っていう話が
ずらずらと続いていく話でございます。
いや！ちょっと待てよ･･･
おむすび･･･
そんなに転がったら
壊れるんじゃね？
そう考えた
一人の男がいた
こんにちわ
Ｄr.はじめだ
皆さんは
「おむすびころりん」という童話を
知っているだろうか
先ほども話したんですけども
あの･･ジジぃ･･･
おじいさんが
おむすびを山で食べてて
んで落としてころころコロコロ
転がって穴に落ちるというお話でございます
そこで私
結構、あの、おにぎりは生きている内で結構食べてる方だと思うんですけども
おにぎりって転がると
ボルゥッって
なるじゃないですか
ボルゥッってなると思ったんですよわたくしは
あの童話の中で
だからひょっとしたら
おにぎりをこの、転がしたらひょっとして
壊れちゃって穴まで落ちる前に
壊れている可能性があるかもしれない
そうなると、この童話には矛盾が生じていることになります
子供にはまちがっても矛盾したことを
教えない様にしていきたいとおもっております、わたくし
なので今回はおにぎりを３種類程準備して
果たしてほんとに
坂からおむすびころりんすると
ころりん中にポロッとならない
事をちょっと検証していきたいと思います
コンビニの３種類ベーシックなやつを準備しました
ファミリーマート
ローソン
セブンイレブン
３つのおにぎりを準備しました
ではここ見てもらえば分かると思うんですけども
坂になっております
車通んないから大丈夫だよ
ここからこう転がして行きます
奥まで行ったらさぁもう僕のイメージだと
大体おむすびころりんした距離はこの、距離なんですよ
おじいさんがこうやってここでおにぎり食ってて
ポロッて行ったやつが多分あそこまで行ってるイメージ
おむすびがあそこまで壊れずにいったら
童話はひとまず、成立
ころりんして
ホールインワンした
ということの証明になると思われます
おれ何しちゃってんだろう
ではやって行こう
最初の選手はこちら
ローソンから行きます
まぁ袋から出さずに行きます、
ちょっと、あの、汚れちゃダメなんで
マジなんの動画だよ
なんかちょっとでも形が崩れたりするともうOUT
それ、もうおにぎりとはいいません
行きます
２･･･ﾌﾌｯ
５０まで来たんですけども、まだ５０だとあんまり壊れてる様子はなさそうでございます
続けていきましょう
100まできました
まだ全然大丈夫じゃない？
１００まで行ってもまだ全然大丈夫です
もうちょっと転がしていきましょう
187、188、189、190
(´Д｀)ﾊｧ…(´Д｀)ﾊｧ…(´Д｀)ﾊｧ…
95、196
197、198、199、200！
はぁ、はぁ、あ”あ”
壊れないよぉ～
いや壊れないですね
まだ全然回転しますし
もうすぐ坂が終わります
このまま行っちゃいましょう
３００行きました～
全然じゃね！？
301、302、303、304、305、306、307
おわんねぇわ
えっ307回転がした塩おにぎりです
意外と転がれるんじゃね説あるよこれ
2週目行きます。
308、309、･･省略(´ω｀*)
400！
400でどぉ？
ちょっと型は崩れてきてるよ
もうひところりん行きます！
500！
はぁ、はぁ、はぁ、はぁ
お爺さん)なるほどねぇ
はじめ)1000回転ぐらいは行きそうですねぇ
お)1000回転くらいねぇ
は)このままだと･･･
お)面白いもんだねぇ
お)いいと･･･ねぇ
お)あんたのぉやっぱそういう
お)あれは積み重ね研究ってもなんでもなぁ
お)面白いなぁもんなぁ
お)なぁ
501、502、503、504、505
･･･省略(´ω｀*)
611、612、613、613･･えっ？
えっ？613?
撮影者)4!4!
4?
さ)4!
616回転目です
ちょ～
ちょっと無敵説あるべ
６１６でしょ
3週目行きましょう
省略(*'ω'*)
696、697、698、699、
え～700!
無敵だお(´;ω;｀)
エンディング
あのずっと回し続けて思ったんですけども
回すごとになんか強度が増して行ってるんだよね
なんかもちもちしてきてて
あぁｗ形がちょっと
ちょっと、ちょっとね、くぼんでいる部分があるんですけども
旨ぁ
ローソンのおにぎりは
ころりんしても崩れません
あと二つわかんないじゃんね
ファミマとセブンひょっとしたら壊れるかもしんないんで
一応あの２つもやっておきます
セットォォ！！
頂きまぁしゅ